when we realize in Christianity would we
have is instead of seeing multiplicity
as Maya or ultimately as illusion we
rather see how its connection to the
center and to the Divine is what fills
it with reality but that that feeling of
reality is is real it's not an illusion
it's not a it's not something that's
evanescent and which will disappear when
we go up into heaven but rather it is a
kind of solidifying of the of the world
in a good way making it glorious and
that's what the Heavenly Jerusalem
ultimately represents is the idea that
no all these things can participate if
they're properly aligned can participate
in the glory of God and will be will be
full of glory and not not in the way
that it will dematerialize them but
rather in the manner in which it makes
them more real and you see that I think
C.S Lewis had great insight about about
that as well he talks about you know the
idea of the the the blades of grass in
Paradise being too sharp for us
something like that like they're
actually too real for us and you see in
the church fathers they say in the
eskatan Saint Paul will be more Saint
Paul and Saint Peter will be more Saint
Peter as they enter into more and more
of their theosis and becoming God more
and more they'd also become more of
themselves
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
and then slowly as I became Orthodox I
kind of moved away from you know
obviously and then with more maturity
seeing some of the limits of his thought
and some of his positions let's say
um and so it's wonderful to ReDiscover
you at this moment
well likewise uh I am
very interested in
the subject of sacred art and in fact I
hope we'll have a chance to talk a
little bit about it today because I
think it's very very important and it's
an area where uh
I come from the Catholic world where the
Catholic World can learn important
lessons from the Orthodox I think the
Orthodox have been far more successful
in preserving sacred art
than we in the west so I'm very eager to
hear uh what you can tell us about that
wonderful
so before we get started I wanted to do
a fairly extensive introduction this
time around for people who might be
joining us who aren't familiar with with
all of these gentlemen and it's going to
take a few minutes so if you want to
skip this part you'll be able to go to
the time stamp and and go right into the
discussion
so as you can see I have a distinguished
panel here today to talk about how to
bring meaning back into our broken world
and for those who are new to these
thinkers I have a fairly um as I said
comprehensive introduction so Dr
Wolfgang Smith graduated in 1948 at the
age of 18 from Cornell University with
three degrees in philosophy physics and
Mathematics that always amazes me and
two years later he obtained his Masters
in physics from Purdue followed by a PhD
in mathematics from Colombia
he he worked as a physicist at the Bell
aircraft Corporation researching
aerodynamics and the problem of
atmospheric re-entry and was a
mathematics professor at MIT UCLA and
Oregon State University doing research
in the field of differential geometry
and he was widely published in academic
journals retiring from academic life in
1992.
Dr Smith is a member of the
traditionalist school of metaphysics
exploring the philosophical
underpinnings of the scientific method
and emphasizing the idea of bringing
science back into the Aristotelian
framework of traditional ontological
realism and away from the bifurcationism
and physical reductionism of scientism
and is a proponent of a new
interpretation of quantum mechanics
called vertical causation
in addition he's the author of many
wonderful books including Cosmos and
Transcendence the vertical Ascent
ancient wisdom and modern misconceptions
along with many others and his newest
book soon to be published is physics a
science inquest of an ontology
Jonathan pegeot graduated with
distinction from the painting and
drawing program at Concordia University
in Montreal during the late 1990s
but quickly disillusioned with
Contemporary Art he discovered icons and
traditional Christian images along his
own spiritual journey
he then studied Orthodox Theology and
iconology at the University of
Sherbrooke his carvings have been
commissioned by Churches bishops priests
and lay people in the United States
Canada Europe and Asia Jonathan is also
a writer and public speaker giving
workshops and conferences all around
North America as well as teaching icon
carving with hexameron is that the right
person
hexameron through his YouTube channel
and podcast the symbolic world he also
furthers the conversation on symbolism
meaning and patterns
Dr Richard Smith did his undergraduate
work at the University of California in
Berkeley his PhD in system science and
his dissertation on generalized
information theory in addition he has
studied complexity science neural
networks genetic algorithms dynamical
systems and systems thinking in addition
to being an entrepreneur helping people
be better investors he is also president
of the philosophia Institute Foundation
which represents the work of Dr Wolfgang
Smith
so gentlemen I welcome you I'm eager to
get started on this conversation
um since you gentlemen are meeting each
other for the first time I thought it
might be helpful to start with Dr
Wolfgang Smith talking a bit about the
icon that represents your concept of the
tripartite cosmos
and then we can follow that by Jonathan
talking a bit about an icon or icons
that are important to him so then I
thought we could use this discussion of
icons to get into a wider discussion of
symbolism and modernity does that sound
okay
yeah very good let's get to it
so Dr Smith
um you want me to share the icon yes
Karen yes for sure
so let me try to explain the idea of the
icon I should say that I'm basically a
platonist
and so this icon could be regarded as a
platonist icon
the ontological ideas is
platonism as well as I think the major
metaphysical traditions of antiquity
have conceived of this integral Cosmos
is tripartite
this I believe is a very important idea
which has been
largely lost even in in academic circles
and and needs to be revived so what are
then these three basic components or
levels of the cosmos well starting at
the lowest
what I call the corporeal world this is
the world as we normally experience it
in our waking state
so it is a world subject to two
conditions two bounds namely space and
time so we the corporeal world is a
spatial temporal world
now on the other end of the spectrum
namely the
Avital you have a realm I call it the EV
Eternal which is subject nicer to space
throughout the time so this is uh
a a a
state implicit in platonist philosophy
and I think actually implicit in all the
great philosophies of the world in one
way or another and between these two
extremes you have something called the
intermediary world
which is subject to time but not to
space now let me say that in certain
parts of the world these ideas have
still been current in my day but in the
West in the Western World this is long
forgotten but I have focused upon this
trichotomy and I have found that it is
remarkably fruitful as a metaphysical
principle it sheds light on many things
that otherwise we would not be able to
grasp and let me point out immediately
that the striped peptide division of the
macrocosm is reflected in man himself in
the anthropos because the anthropos is
likewise tripartite in traditional terms
this is a trip Edition into Corpus
animal spiritus Body Soul and Spirit
intellect
so that uh this icon
applies to the microcosm as well as to
the market causing we are tripartite
beings in a tripartite
universe and so I've tried to revive
this tripartite
uh understanding of both men and Cosmos
and apply it to various
questions of Interest beginning with the
philosophy of physics
the philosophy of physics is greatly a
deeply impacted by this idea of the
tripartite cosmos
to give just one example in a sense the
most striking of all it can be
rigorously affirmed that the mere
existence of the intermediary domain in
other words the existence of a domain
subject to time but not to space has
profound implications for physics and in
fact it enables one on a rigorous
ontological basis to prove the
impossibility of einsteinian physics and
it's very easy to see actually because
if you have an intermediary domain you
evidently have a globally defined
concept of simultaneity and as every
physicist will understand if in
relativity Theory you do not have a
globally defined concept of simultaneity
so very clearly the tripartite cosmos
invalidates Einstein in physics so I
mentioned this as an example that
ontology does have something to say even
on a scientific basis so these are the
ideas I've been developing and they have
implications as you might expect not
only to physics but to many domains of
primary interest
so that's a surprise for as an
introduction
thank you Dr Smith
so Jonathan do you would you like to
share a screen and show something well I
might have a question just about the
icon so in the image that was shown the
so the center would be the spirit would
be the the spiritual the line would be
the intermediary and the periphery would
be the
corporeal is that is that the right
understanding exactly Jonathan that's
exactly right
okay and so do you project this this
this
um can you project this icon into three
three-dimensional space in the sense of
a mountain let's say or a pyramid with
the point at the summit representing the
uh a connection of some kind to see it
like this if you flipped it have you
thought about about it that way in any
manner
I think it would weaken the
uh iconographic effect
all right so okay so do you wanna so I
might I might want to bring up one other
thing that Dr Smith didn't mention here
um if I'm not presuming too much um
Wolfgang in um
in your book physics and vertical
causation you talk about the
The Straight Edge and the compass and
how
the point um is that the
the construction enters the picture and
bestows a dynamic aspect in addition to
its static form
the circle of us becomes something more
than a closed circular Arc it comes to
be perceived as a circular art swept out
by a compass
which as you mentioned later on in the
book it it performs the unlikely feat of
bringing time into the picture
because as the as the compass sweeps out
the ark it's actually
um bringing time into the picture
do you would you like to comment on that
Wolfgang
well let me just say uh that I was
thinking especially of the platonist
school uh the platonists seemed to have
uh
been very very fascinated with geometry
which they regarded as actually a tool
uh in this in the comprehension of
metaphysics
and they thought of geometry as
concerned with geometric construction in
other words they were not interested in
regarding a geometric figure or diagram
simply as as that
they regarded it as something to be
constructed with the two geomatic
instruments The Straight Edge and the
compass and uh
I don't want to say too much about that
because it actually leads into very
difficult
questions it's not an easy subject but I
sense that
this meditations if you will there's
platonous meditations on Geometry as
they understood it were deeply
meaningful in a metaphysical sense and
in particular the understanding of time
was related to the figure of the compass
for example when Plato says time is the
moving image of Eternity
I think to to make this somehow
graspable
Ness here is sinking of actually a
compass sweeping out the circle
so and incidentally
uh in in
this regard let me say that the
traditional platonist view of time is
circular
so
let this be all for a first introduction
to these platonix ideas and they are
difficult but in my opinion tremendously
meaningful for an understanding of
metaphysics
and and I might add
my experience of this icon
right is a before really understanding
this icon
I was stuck in the outer shell of this
reality right and so all my work in
Academia in science and artificial
intelligence and Technology Etc
was an attempt to
um
try to understand
the whole of reality
by only being able to examine the outer
edge of reality right and uh and
actually science isn't even dealing with
the outer edge of this icon here it's
dealing with kind of the quantitative
attributes of the outer edge of this
icon
and so
um to have that aha right to learn about
Wolfgang's work and then realize kind of
how we got to this point of only
considering the quantitative attributes
of this outer edge of this icon as being
kind of the parts from which we are to
then recreate the whole
um that was a very big reveal to me
right and so then once you kind of
acknowledge that if you do agree with
that and you say whoa that sounds right
you know then you do have to say well
what is the real structure of the whole
and
um so this icon comes out of uh
traditional
um
wisdom traditions
throughout you know Mankind and uh and
speaks of the these three parts right
the kind of outer edge the the
avaternal or the the
um spiritus and then kind of this middle
world
of uh soul I think and psyche and it's
just a wonderful way to
begin to you know reapproach
um our understanding and try to make
sense of things
Jonathan no I I think I I think I I
understand the the the icon I think
the reason why I was pointing to the the
possibility of flipping it is mostly if
we want I think that if we want to use
your image
as a key let's say to sometimes to
understanding sacred art there are some
moments where we would need to do that
can you know you know in the symbolism
of the Cross he traces this he kind of
does that where he he creates the notion
that the center of the circle
can also be seen as an axis and that the
periphery of the circle can be seen as a
coil and that would account for the
relationship between the different
microcosms and microcosms and how they
kind of embed each other uh embed
themselves into each other
um and so if I don't know if maybe this
could be an interesting possibility of
showing maybe some traditional or some
images the from the Christian tradition
and try to see how they can connect to
this image
would that make sense well one example
actually uh of of a three-dimensional
version of this would be a church itself
and so the Orthodox Church would have a
dome with Christ at the at the top of
the Dome
uh and then the circle moving down into
a square
and so you would have the The Dome
coming down being held by four
pendatives and on those four pendantives
would be let's say the corners which
would which would be an extreme actually
version of that
Circle or even a more embodied version
of that Circle down in the let's say the
four manifestations of the one
and you'll see that represented as the
four evangelists or as the four beasts
in Ezekiel
um and so if you if you project that
image into space there are ways to to
account for other traditional forms like
architecture
um like uh some of the icons that exist
in in the in the church and also let's
say the iconographic programs that are
in the church will have that form so a
good example another example would be
the Dome itself
in in traditional Byzantine churches the
Dome represents the Ascension itself and
so the earliest domes would have Christ
up at the access point in the middle of
the Dome and then around the periphery
of the Dome you would have the mother of
God Mary which would be directly under
him and then you would have the 12
disciples which would be circling the
Dome and so you have that that
relationship between the principle and
its manifestation right from from Christ
as the Divine man into the twelve that
are has a cosmic aspect but also has a
has the notion of the body of the church
itself and so you can kind of see that
uh manifested that way so that's one of
the reasons why I wanted to to to to see
if you had thought about how you can
project it that way because I think that
I think that the icon or the image of
the center and the periphery is
obviously the most basic image to
understand reality and now you I use it
in different guises uh all the time so
so I I don't know much about science and
so it's hard for me to to know like
let's say why it invalidates einsteinian
uh physics but I definitely see how that
structure is
you can re you can you can use the
center and periphery as it as a
structure to explain everything you can
basically explain the entire Cosmos with
that with that basic structure
I uh I guess I've been accustomed to
differentiate
iconography
from sacred art and sacred architecture
at Large
I I I certainly agree completely with
what you say about sacred architecture
but I always regarded
iconography as is as a little part of
that I I always regarded icons as
two-dimensional am I am I wrong there
you know more about this than I do
well I think I think so I think it
depends on if you understand that icons
were are not divorced from the Sacred
Space that is icons were developed as
iconographic programs the idea of the
panel icon
there's nothing wrong with the panel
icon but in the Byzantine in the midi in
the Romanesque period or in the
Byzantine period the icon would have
been first and foremost
and experience as uh spatial
relationships in the church and so
certain images would appear in certain
places within the church or the Eastern
apps would have an image for example in
the Byzantine tradition for example the
Eastern apps would have an image of the
mother of god with Christ uh
pre-incarnate Christ in her Center and
then on the western side of the church
you would have for example the falling
asleep of the Virgin where now Christ is
holding the soul of the mother of God in
her hands now if you if you look at the
image of the the death of the mother of
God or the the the falling asleep and
you see Christ holding the soul of the
virgin in his hands it's very confusing
if you don't understand that it was
originally understood in space as a as
an answer to the Eastern apps and the
the mother of god with Christ in her
Center so it's like a reflection of East
and West Sunrise Sunset right this this
kind of inversion that happens at the
beginning in at the end so I think that
in order to really understand icons we
have to
remember that they were they were mostly
spatially experienced inside
iconographic programs and this from the
time of uh of Constantine right right
right at the outset the earliest
churches that were created in the
constantinian period use this
apocalyptic apocalyptic imagery in in
the church architecture and then also
integrating gospel stories and different
images so
although yes the image itself if you
look at it it is in some ways a vertical
right it's a vertical relationship there
isn't much going on in that in the in
the spatial they are meant to inhabit a
uh a 3D space yeah
well Jonathan uh one of the things that
I was talking with Wolfgang about before
you joined us was
the difference between
um traditional art and then art after
the Renaissance when more and more
perspective came in more emphasis on
form more emphasis on depth in the image
and I was just guessing because I'm no
expert on iconography but I was guessing
that
um if we go back to his icon of the the
EV Eternal Being A Place With No Time in
space and then the intermediary being in
place with only time
it seems to me that that iconography
fits into the intermediary in the sense
that there is it's mostly
two-dimensional so there's not a sense
of space within the work itself
but there is a sense of time because
some of your icons show all the time at
one time
but in a two-dimensional image
and I don't know if if that's at all
interesting idea yeah well for sure
managers yeah well one of the advantages
of icons is is the possibility of
showing simultaneity you know and it's
the difference between a story and an
image a story will will string events in
a pattern right in the line whereas in
in an icon you can experience it the
entire story in a simultaneous image and
then the the spatial relationships of
the elements uh will be meaningful
rather than how they fit in sequence of
time so it's it's it is a play between
space and time because obviously an
image is this fully spatial image it I
mean it's it's a spatial uh experience
because you're you're experiencing it
but you're also it's a it's a window
into simultaneity because you get the
possibility maybe I can show the images
I did make a few images last year or
maybe some of them two years ago which
were trying to Encompass I call them you
know images of everything or or Cosmic
images would try to encompass
all of this narrative into one single
image
um do you need to give me can I share do
you think yes please do okay let's see I
haven't carved these yet they're just
designs and so these are two
um efforts that I I made to to create
images or Cosmic images which would try
to Encompass let's say
entire narratives into single images and
so on the left you have this image of
the cosmic Mountain the mountain of
paradise
um and it's it's also a commentary in
some ways on San ephraim's him Zone
paradise and also saying Greg
rivenessa's life of Moses all of these
this these types of structures coming in
at the same time so if you look at the
image uh you will see of course this
different characters appear several
times in this same image you have Adam
and Eve appearing at the tree and then
Adam and Eve covering themselves with
the Fig leaves and then Adam and Eve
covered with the garments of skin
and then you also have an increase of
division from The Singularity of the
Cross into a splitting in half until you
have Adam and Eve completely separated
and then the Thorns which have you know
multiplicity uh let's say
multiplicity itself as the as the thorns
um
and then you have of course Adam and Eve
transformed ultimately into the mother
of God and Saint John up at the tree of
life which is shown as the cross
um
and so these these types of image so you
also have so sand Ephraim talks about
how the rivers of these four rivers
talked about this idea of the Dome and
how the Dome moves into four into a
square how the circle moves into a
square and you see that in uh in the
image of paradise itself so if you if
you can represent it you get a sense of
this
this dome which becomes a square with
the wall of paradise so it's also a
church and you have these four currents
which come down and which are mitigated
as they get further and further away
from the uh from The Source let's say
um
and so these are these are a few you see
and so in now the the other one is of
course the image of the flood
and so you have this let's say microcosm
of this so this image here
of of paradise is now inserted in the
background as the just the tree and the
mountain the wall and the four rivers
and the flood comes right up to the to
the the wall of paradise so basically
all of this here in the first image is
now what's represented here
um so it's also a way to kind of show
how these microcosm fit into each other
and then the Arc of course becomes a
microcosm as well
of the hierarchy which we see in the
different images and so you know with
the birds the birds above
and then the animals below and then
death of course at the bottom and
residues
of civilization residues of religion
residues of animality all these residues
which are in in the mouth of Hades which
is this is down here below
these are all pulled out of of course
traditional images this is It's a
condensation of traditional images but
all of the elements are taken from
different iconographic strains so they
say the mouth of Hell or the mouth of
death is a very ancient image that we
find in iconography
um
same with the Leviathan this is of
course the Leviathan but it's also
Jonah's monster
um there are different elements to to to
look at how I tried to pull it all into
one into into what very condensed images
so what do you hope people what what
impact do you hope this will have on
people who
well these particular images I think
what they do for people is they first of
all surprise them
because they they at first get a sense
that there's a coherence but they they
can't access it rationally right away
um and then slowly if they know their
Bible this is of course it's mostly
useful for people that know their Bible
if they know their Bible then things
will start to appear and start to to
kind of take form and and make sense and
then they'll start to realize
that for example you know the crown of
thorns which is around the the
Paradise here is also lifted up by
Christ as being this ultimate you know
apathetic image
above
um and then people start to notice how
the image comes together and to realize
the the Deep coherence of the biblical
story The Deep coherence of these images
um
and so yes that is what I'm hoping to to
accomplish with these images it's
um just a kind of personal story as I
have
um or experiences I've gone deeper into
Christianity myself and I look at just
the symbolism of the Cross right
it's amazing how much
um
has opened to me from just contemplating
that icon
whereas before before I was open to a
religious
life I guess I had dismissed that icon
entirely right even though I had been
you know raised nominally Christian
um
but you know to me that's what is really
um kind of the burning question right is
if this approach that we have to you
know knowledge and understanding today
this kind of science physics based in
time sequential cause and effect
versus really
engaging with symbols
and and the reality of the symbols
themselves right uh as I go deeper into
that it's just opening up a whole new
world of new worlds of understanding
that we're kind of you know excluded
before because these were just regarded
as mythological and something from an
earlier time and not really of value to
the modern man yeah
let me let me just here maybe I can show
this image
and show how it connects to Dr Smith's
uh Circle and the periphery so this is
of course this now it's a carving that
I've done of Christ pulling Saint Peter
from The Waters
and I think that in this image we see a
very a very beautiful version of what uh
Wolfgang is talking about in terms of
the relationship between Center
periphery and something we could call
memory uh there are different ways to
represent the intermediary World memory
is definitely one of them
uh and so we have of course Christ who
represents in this in this image
represents the the center
and then Peter who is falling into the
periphery
he's falling into the periphery because
he forgets his connection to Christ
and and he he thinks that it's on his
own he thinks that he can do it all by
himself that he can walk on the waters
without being connected to the
Incarnation
and because of that that's why he falls
and in and in calling out to Christ
right in Remembering God remembering
Christ remembering the heart all these
images we find in traditional uh
parlance then he is able to be pulled
back out of the chaos and stand firmly
on the
on the multiplicity that is the world
um and in this image I wanted to show
how Christ the way that he engages with
multiplicity is he transforms it into
glory and so when his foot touches when
his foot touches the waters it actually
sends golden spirals out from the place
where he touches the the the periphery
we could say
let me just interject Jonathan that
these carvings are perfectly beautiful
they're amazing
thank you
and I've never seen this style of
carving it's is is that unique to to you
it's
well it's based on I mean it's based on
Byzantine style but of course it you
know we
how can I say this we we're not
idiosyncratic we're all I mean we're not
uh nostalgic for the past I'm not trying
to make Pastiche images of ancient art
I'm trying to create images that both
connect with the past and with the
ancient forms but also have
enough element of of surprise to make
you
um to not make you ignore it let's say
or to not make you walk by and think
that it's
let me show you here's an image of Jonah
which is I I chose these images because
they're related to the question of the
of the icon and so here again we have a
similar image as the image of Saint
Peter which is that Jonah is being eaten
by the monster he's being eaten by this
Leviathan here
that's in the waters by the the sea
monster and then he says from the belly
of death I cry I cried and you heard my
voice and so from the belly of this this
chaos and multiplicity he remembers God
and therefore is brought out of the
waters into the city
beautiful
so right the um you know the the
multiplicity with the corporeal world
and the
um
Christ or God with the avaternal world
here
for a Wolfgang's icon
yes well it's to me the way that I see
the icon the I see it really as a as a
fractal structure and so
it it represents itself relatively at
different levels and so for example
let's say
you can let's say if you have a um
let's say you have a group a team or a
nation or something then you can see how
that structure will represent itself and
there'll be stand-ins let's say a
stand-in for the center would be the
king of course the king is not
spiritual the king is an embodied person
but it because it manifests itself uh
fractally then you can understand that
there are images which are more
appropriate to to see it at it in its
highest form and so of course
um
in this image the the you don't see the
center it's up here right it's up in
what he's looking at it's it's up where
he's looking at up here sometimes it's
represented as a
I don't know if you've ever seen this
which is the which is the Divine Glory
uh it's a Divine Darkness actually and
so usually you'll have a dark a dark
semi-circle at the top of many images
and that it moves from Darkness into
light so it really is this kind of
apophatic image of the Transcendent and
so here's a here's a hostile version of
the of this question
where where now it is in some ways
this this connection here between the
center and the the periphery which is
held by the intermediary being
and is of course the source of it is the
Transcendent the Transcendent up here is
now more of a hostile
image it's more of a
pushing down or preventing it from
devouring the uh devouring the world
um
so they're obviously there are different
ways to represent the the sometimes it's
a beneficial relationship sometimes it
can be a hostile relationship depending
on the different the things you want to
emphasize
so Jonathan is that St Michael yes
yeah I'd say Michael killing the
Leviathan
yeah you see that in Revelation it says
Saint Michael the great the Great Dragon
was uh
was pushed down by Saint Michael and the
the Leviathan well I wanted to ask a
clarifying question of Dr Wolfgang Smith
um
in order to ask the question I'm going
to read a quote of yours um from another
one of your books Dr Smith do you want
me to stop the share maybe it'll be a
good idea no you you can leave it on
there it's beautiful to look it's
beautiful to look at yeah
the EV Eternal realm is inherently the
cosmos in its integrality before it is
fragmented into innumerable bits and
pieces
through the imposition of temporal and
spatial bounds yet despite this
partition into spatial temporal
fragments every corporeal entity X
remains undivided in its very being
this gives an identity I guess that's
Multiplicity
but it also made me wonder about the EV
Eternal realm is there anything above
the of Eternal realm or is the ebaternal
realm
the the aboveness
oh it's a wonderful question
the answer that I would give is this
I am presupposing a categorical
distinction between God and the creation
um
my ontology
is
uh a cosmic ontology in other words I do
not engage in any kind of theology I
engage in
in straight
Cosmic
uh ontology so uh the cosmos is one
thing and God is infinitely above the
cosmos but I don't write about God I I
write about the cosmos
so your icon is is the cosmos but God is
infinitely other
God is infinitely other he's not part of
the
the the icon refers to the cosmos not
the Gods so Jonathan maybe that answers
your question about why it's
uh flat rather than
um
a mountain
because because God is at the top of the
mountain as God is above the top of the
mountain let's let's put it that way
um
so yeah now we could stop screen sharing
here and and uh maybe we could go on to
talk about this issue of the symbolism
of the Cross because I found this quote
from John barrella
quite fascinating Jonathan are you
familiar with John Barella yeah okay so
um in his book symbolism and reality
um he's talking about what he learned
from Renee and and he's and Barilla says
to the basic cosmological question what
is the reality of the physically real
materialism is incapable of providing
the least response by wanting to reduce
um the historical physically real to its
space-time conditioning and material
substantiality
far from saving it or issuing its
consistency or rooting it in being and
guaranteeing its objective existence
they positively destroy it since they
subject it to fragmentation to the
indefinite divisibility of space-time
and matter
if the Cross of Christ is only made of
two pieces of wood then it vanishes in
the scattering and inconstancy of an
electron mist
so I wondered if the three of you would
discuss the symbolism of the cross
um if it's not just particles
if it's not just wood what what are all
the aspects of the symbolism of the
cross
I mean I think what just um
what I what really stand stood out to me
about that borella quote is his
um in the first sentence right about
that the uh
can you read that first sentence over
again
sure
um to the basic cosmological question
what is the reality of the physically
real yes
materialism is incapable of providing
the least response exactly
and therein lies the rub right that's
kind of where we're stuck because we're
trying to use materialism to interrogate
everything when meanwhile it can't even
answer the question of its own existence
and so we have to look beyond that
which is why I think we're all here
yeah and I think I think that the cross
just in terms of geometry it is the
place where
the identity of something and its
multiple elements meet that's the that's
the best way to understand it where the
vertical and horizontal meet that is
that place of communion that place of
love where the multiple can become one
without annulling its multiplicity and
that's a mystery I think that people are
faced with now is that we perceive and
we we can identify Unity at different
levels and different objects but we can
a simultaneous in like simultaneously
realize that those unities are made up
of multiplicities this is true
you know it happens at every level all
the way down and it seems to go all the
way up and and this is of course the
problem that a lot of fields are trying
to account for or deal with today they
come up with terms like emergence which
I love how David Bentley Hart said said
emergence just means magic it's like
magic happens here and then all of a
sudden we have one just because you have
a word doesn't mean you understand the
process uh and so this is of course the
mystery which I do believe that more
traditional visions of of uh ontological
hierarchies
answers and the The Mystery of the cross
in terms of Christianity and it's
something which I find which is
difficult to fully Pierce is that it
seems what Christ is showing to us is
that what's at the center is something
like sacrifice
and it's something like self-sacrifice
it that seems to be what happens at the
middle
um
so that's what I can propose at the
outset
I very much like what you just said
Jonathan
about the cross that uh the most Salient
point is this point of intersection the
idea that the vertical which
in a way it represents God and the
horizontal which represents the creation
that they can intersect
and there are many ways I think of
interpreting that but beginning with the
idea that the Incarnation itself
represents an intersection of these two
dimensions
and incidentally let me just remark on
this that
you mentioned renege and you you said
I'm a perennials
let me say that this is something that
the perennialists don't do do not
understand
they do not understand this intersection
because the perennialists are
essentially uh inspired by The Vedic
tradition which is the oldest in the
world and the Very venerable tradition
indeed
but it is very very different from the
Christian that the two are not the same
and uh
I think it is very very important for
the Christians to understand the
uniqueness of the Christian vision of
the Christian Revelation and it lies in
this intersection
this intersection is nowhere represented
in The Vedic it is not there
this is also why the idea of Salvation
is nowhere in The Vedic tradition the
Nirvana is blowing out it is a union
with God undoubtedly but it is a union
in which the human is
incinerated
and the uniqueness of Christianity is
something that The Vedic people don't
understand renege no never understood it
sure never understood it and it is true
that I was sort of
impressed by The Perennial school I read
a lot of the works and I was inspired by
it but eventually I realized that the
Christian tradition transcends that in a
completely uh
fundamental way and that the Christian
escort on of Salvation is
incomprehensible in fact in The Vedic
tradition if you try to explain that to
the most educated sadhus in India they
will not understand what you're saying
I think you're inside I mean I think the
Insight you've had is the same that I
had at some point and also came to love
Christianity and realize that you know
you know a lot of people have said it
that you just didn't understand
Christianity maybe he also didn't have
the right sources I don't know or he had
bad he had obviously had bad experiences
also with the with the Catholic church
at his at the time of his own in his own
experience but I think I think you're
right that would we realize in
Christianity would we have is instead of
seeing multiplicity as Maya or
ultimately as illusion we rather see how
its connection to the center and to the
Divine is what fills it with reality but
that that feeling of reality is is real
it's not an illusion it's not a it's not
something that's evanescent and which
will disappear when we go up into heaven
but rather it is a kind of solidifying
of the of the world in a good way making
it glorious and that's what the Heavenly
Jerusalem ultimately represents is the
idea that no all these things can
participate if they're properly aligned
can participate in the glory of God and
will be will be full of glory and not
not in the way that it will
dematerialize them but rather in the
manner in which it makes them more real
and you see that I think C.S Lewis had
great insight about about that as well
he talks about you know the idea of the
the the blades of grass in Paradise
being too sharp for us something like
that like they're actually too real for
us and you see in the church fathers
they say and yes Katan Saint Paul will
be more Saint Paul and Saint Peter will
be more Saint Peter as they enter into
more and more of their theosis and
becoming God more and more they've also
become more of themselves
very well put and and this is something
that is
uh completely
uncomprehended in the perennialist world
view they they have they have no
comprehension with it all and in fact
they look upon Christianity through
vedantic eyes
and through vedantic eyes you will never
see Christianity it's invisible once you
put these Spectacles on
and so
this is I think a very important point
which uh needs to be uh explained to
interested people because there's a
tremendous confusion about this in the
world today most of the so-called
intellectuals the world over are in a
sense perennials today and this is very
unfortunate
yeah and I think Christianity ultimately
is in some ways a better solution to the
problem of or the question of
non-duality it actually presents a
fuller
a fuller
a fuller solution to that problem right
which is that we do not deny the
infinite infinite Transcendence of God
but in that infinite Transcendence
all of reality can participate I I don't
see how you can find a better solution
to the problem of of Duality rather than
wanting to extinguish manifestation and
see it as some kind of delusion or
Illusion or or evanescent uh some some
kind of uh Mist you know that will be
this that will be kind of scattered uh
once things return to God it's like well
then what are those then what what is
their purpose like what is what purpose
do they serve
we literally could say you know Christ
saves the world that's right exactly and
it's and he says it through elevation
itself right and you can see that
somebody
who's been through the science and the
Western education right and the
materialism which can explain itself and
ends up being empty and nothing
and then the Hindu traditions and kind
of all of the Eastern Traditions that
basically pursue that kind of Maya
Extinction uh path to actual salvation
right that Christ saves the world
literally restores
substance meaning to the world and I
would add not just through sacrifice but
through love yeah right yeah love
becomes the bindings
and where else do you
learn about love
in the same way that you do from
Christianity right and and uh so to go
back to Karen's original question about
the symbolism of the Cross right it is
the symbol of love
and and that love is what makes things
real
well yeah some people think that's just
a sappy statement but I think it's the
deepest metaphysical statement that you
can make because love is the coexistence
of unity and multiplicity that's what
love is because if you love something
you don't want it to vanish you don't
want it to disappear you want it to
exist as different from you and then be
bound bound to it at the same time and
so it's actually it's one of the most
beautiful
ways to understand how all the creation
can coexist with God and within God
so you said love is the unity of you
know love is the coexistence okay in
unity yes I'd like to jump in here just
a minute because before I forget what
you said Jonathan you said that the
connection to the Divine is what fills
it with reality
solidifying the world in a good way and
I just love that language because I've
been meditating for a long time on that
verse faith is the substance of things
hoped for
because my belief is that the Bible is
truer than true it's so deeply true that
it's not not a scientific book but when
you when you read the scripture
it's as though
deep scientific truths were buried in
there for us to find when we when we
matured enough to find them and to me
Faith is the substance of things hoped
for is exactly what you said
the Divine fills fills it with reality
so this thing hoped for is the thing
that is is posited or is is uh
the the vision that you have for
something and then Faith fills that with
reality it fills it with substance it it
fleshes it out so to speak so
um
a while back I I did a video on the
quality of the sacrifice
thinking about sacrifice not just as um
how we think of
like dying on the cross or giving up
your time for others or something well
yeah okay but the idea of opportunity
cost that every everything that you do
means a whole lot of other things that
you don't do right so the quality of
that sacrifice determines the nature of
what comes into being as a result of
that sacrifice right
that made me ask the question so what
exactly is it that we are measuring when
we measure because I've been stuck on
this measurement problem in physics for
a long time and
um
I really think that the measurement
problem is deeply tied to sacrifice and
I haven't
thought my way all all the way through
that but I would love to have a
physicist point of view on that so
Wolfgang if you could you don't have to
answer right now but if you could just
give that some thought because you talk
quite a bit in your book about how
we are meeting out we are measuring out
time we are measuring out all these
things in in
everything that we do so I think
measurement and sacrifice and somehow
this idea that Jonathan said about
our connection to the Divine is what
fills the world with reality
I think
it is very necessary very important
to represent
Christianity in this
current debate because
it seems to me the perennialists and
they are represented by a very very
brilliant people
again on and chew on
they have been as it were winning the
argument and no one has stood up to
represent the Christian side
and I'm
completely convinced that in the
the conception of the Triune God we have
the resolution of this dichotomy of Atma
Maya if you if you read what the
perennialists have to say on this
subject you find that they cannot get
Beyond this dichotomy
and so for example in practice this
means that if you want to actually
attain to reality attained to the
Supreme wisdom you have to
of course give up Maya and
the Christian way is much more subtle
than that because uh
the Christian ontology is based not upon
two but upon three and this is where
salvation comes into play
the
Christian conception of the Triune God
somehow saves you from this vedantic
dichotomy
and this is something that uh needs to
be
communicated to the intellectual world
today because as I see it they are
fascinated by the perennialist message
which is a
in a sense it's a denial of the christic
Revelation in favor of The Vedic
foreign
yeah when we if we understand the story
of Christ we'll see that one of the
things that Christ is doing pretty much
all the time in his story is he's
constantly transforming death into Glory
that's the best way to understand it and
so he's filling the the aspects it's
it's a narrative the crown of thorns is
the best version of that because
the crown of thorns is of course the
consequence of the falls it is
multiplicity itself or it's like hostile
multiplicity we could say all these
spiky things that that pierce us and
then Christ is able to transform that
into a crown
and then you realize that that's what
Christ is actually doing all the time
which is why he goes to the margin all
the time why he why he engages with the
the
um the Samaritan woman for example here
here's a woman who's had several
husbands to the extent that now she's
living in an illegitimate relationship
with a man and so she's a [ __ ] for all
intents and purposes and narrative
narrative constructs and Christ is
saying I will marry you
right I will be your seventh husband and
I will give you water that will flow
into eternity and so he takes her low
State and brings it up and he does that
constantly whether it's the woman with
the issue of blood whether it's and
whether it's Resurrection itself like
that's what Resurrection is it is a
transformation of death into Glory so
this the whole story of Christ the whole
you know not just as an abstract image
of the Incarnation but in the story we
see how Christ is constantly showing us
how the world even death itself can be
full and transformed into into light so
yeah
I love it
beautiful
so Karen I wanted to understand your
question just a little better about yeah
I'm sorry
so flustered looking at all of you
because your brain is also much bigger
than mine but Karen I have an Insight in
your question if you want if you want to
maybe I can see yeah is that it's that
without without an identity you can't
measure anything
you can't you don't measure things
without identity identity is pre
measurement presupposes identity we
presuppose is uh Telos and then
presupposes a bound something that binds
it and those are the two sacrifices
right there the sacrifices of Yom Kippur
there's a sacrifice up towards identity
towards that the source of identity and
then there's a scapegoat sacrifice of
cutting off that which doesn't belong
within the identity and so without those
two sacrifices without giving up all
your best up towards the identity and
without cutting off that which doesn't
belong you can't measure there's no
possibility of measuring
uh and so so measurement is that it has
to be bound up in the notion of
sacrifice
so fascinating because I mean one of the
reasons I came to the conclusion I came
to is because of my work
as an artist and in creativity thinking
about the elements and principles of
design
and how boundary is so important in the
way that you establish well first of all
boundaries are so important in the way
that you establish your work you have to
have
limitations and constraints before you
can even get started because there's
just too many choices otherwise so so
the boundary sets a place where within
which creativity can exist
and then
one of the things that we always
discovered when we're working is that
sometimes you're painting
and you realize there's this one
beautiful little spot over here in this
corner and you don't want to lose that
spot but you need to you need to repaint
so you need to give up that precious
thing in order to get to get to the next
step to get to the next level and this
is like what you're talking about the
down cutting off the scapegoat you know
getting rid of that scapegoat thing
um in order to go up towards the
identity you have to cut off the other
part and I think also that really
resonates with me Jonathan in the whole
area of addiction
because
um I as I've talked about many times on
my channel I have a problem with
just giving in all the time oh just a
little bite of this won't hurt a little
bit of that water but it actually does
hurt and so because part of what it does
is it um
it it leaves this way out so that you
don't have to look up
but
so I've understood that part but what
you're saying here about the down I
think that's the part that I haven't
gotten a handle on the cutting off
so could you could you say that again
about the the up is towards the identity
and the down is well it's really the Yom
Kippur sacrifice that's really the you
could say there are two goats there's
one pure goat which is offered up to God
and then becomes the meal that we eat so
right so we give up and then we get a
blessing but we also get cohesion
because we eat the meal together so we
eat the goat and we become we share the
same body because we sacrifice up but
then there's also an aspect of the Yom
Kippur sacrifice which is putting your
sins
on the the goat and chasing it out of
the of the city and so that is the
cutting off of that which doesn't belong
within an identity right so I've said it
I joke about it all the time but you
can't make an automobile out of gerbils
right that is a scapegoat aspect there's
some things that you have to eliminate
that it almost happens naturally that
are eliminated depending on the Telos
that you're aiming for now of course in
the case of Christ it's important to
understand that Christ is both goats
Christ has both at the same time right
that's one of the things that makes it
so hard to understand his story Christ
is both the sacrifice of good odor which
goes up and the Goat which is sacrificed
outside of Jerusalem the one that is
cast out he does both he he joins those
two sacrifices into one and a
Transcendent sacrifice
I'd just like to make a quick connection
between one of the things you said
Jonathan and Wolfgang's work which is
you can't have measurement without
identity right yeah and uh that is in
essence how Wolfgang resolves the
measurement problem from quantum physics
right like measurement by itself as an
abstract Standalone
um
What entity substance uh doesn't doesn't
exist right and so to just try to answer
these questions that can't be answered
by measurement with measurement right
and then to use the hand waving terms of
emergence and Consciousness Etc to say
you know well if you just get enough of
them together you know if our computers
get fast enough and and our data
collection gets vast enough we're gonna
see it you know it's gonna pop out
but no measurement can't happen without
identity I I like to say of Wolfgang's
work my one sentence summary is the
measurer cannot be measured
and that is you know really what turned
me from finally going okay thank you I
no longer have to seek all the answers
in this domain which is not capable of
giving them to me uh time to go look
somewhere else
and it's crazy how people some it's so
difficult because you say that but there
are thousands and thousands of people
which will hear you say that and not
know what you're talking about yeah I I
keep telling people identities are given
identities are a gift from Heaven they
come down from above obviously I do it
on purpose to really push them it's like
you cannot get to identities from below
it is not possible it is absolutely
impossible they they they're a
revelation of God there's no other way
to encounter them they come down from
heaven and bound phenomena together into
into unities there's no way around it
there was a just a little you know this
week there was a big or in the past
couple of weeks there was a big story
out about self-driving cars right and
there's uh about how here we are 10
years later and they can't make left
turns right so
um
because
we have this other dimension of our
experience Wolfgang might call it
irreducible wholeness you're calling it
identity
um we're able to do things that this
strictly you know in time and space
uh modeling can't do
right the simplest things like turn left
yeah yeah and then you see this video of
Elon Musk saying literally for the past
seven years we're gonna have fully
self-driving cars next year by next year
you know you guys 90 of your time you're
not gonna have your hands on the wheel
right and what's interesting about can't
happen what's fascinating about the AI
this has been really fascinating to me
to notice is that what they're doing
they're inverting their relationship
right and so what they're actually doing
inverting the matrix it's an upside down
Matrix what they're doing is they're
farming they're farming for intelligence
so the way they train the AI actually is
is human selecting yeah so they have all
these humans selecting and that is what
provides intelligence to the AI and so
whatever intelligence the AI has will
always come from Human selection telling
them that's the good one that's the bad
one that's the good behavior that's the
bad behavior because the machine can
never get get there on its own they're
modeling intelligence
and the intelligence comes from humans
and all the algorithms are run by human
selection
and I don't want to you know get us off
track but just I think it's also
interesting how
that Paradigm you know that view of the
world allows a very few people to kind
of be the authorities that tells
everybody else you know how things work
and what's going to happen
there honey so Elon Musk and say for
seven years now trust me we're gonna
have self-driving cars next year right
and more money is raised more capitals
raised more Powers accumulated
and uh and it's just not true
it does bring up an interesting point
about how in
the idea that we can impose identity on
something
we can choose a new identity or impose
identity on something and as Jonathan
said identity is a gift I mean uh
Jonathan you and John pravaky talk a lot
about the cup
the cup or
um Wolfgang talks about the Apple the
Apple
has all this multiplicity I mean if you
started taking an apple apart it would
be endless number of particles that are
involved in an apple and and not just
the physical particles but all the
things that you could imagine that an
apple could do or be or the way that it
gets taken up into our bodies it's just
completely combinatorial explosive and
yet and yet there is an apple
and yet it is red and yet it has a taste
and a fragrance and And We crave them
so um it there's also an aspect of
identity that I wondered if you guys
could talk about a little bit which is
coherence over time
because one of the theories I've gotten
extremely interested in recently not
because I think it's true but because I
think there are a lot of metaphysical
Concepts that can be thought about
inside this Theory and that is Stephen
wolfram's theory of a new fundamental
physics which I don't need to go into
here but but in there he does talk about
this idea of coherence over time and how
identities persist
and so I wondered if you guys could talk
about that a little bit
I mean my arm can move through space and
it's the same arm whether it's whether
the particles are in this configuration
or this configuration or they're over
here or it's moving through time or my
body is moving through time why is it
that that I consist
what is the name of the person who whom
you're referring to now Stephen Wolfram
if you're interested Wolfgang I can send
you a lot of material it's a very
beautiful Theory because
that I'll just give you a very simple
basic idea that space rather than just
being a container space is actually made
of particles
each particle is a node
each node is connected to the other
particles through an edge
so everything is in relationship and
time is the updating of the changing of
the the confirmation of these
so
I'll have to send you some graphics of
it but the first icon that he shows
for his uh
I'll very quickly draw it out
here's the first icon that it shows
so this is the beginning
there's a rule the rule executes and
creates this
and then
when the rule executes the next time
it'll take this Edge and reproduce this
thing
and then it'll take an edge from that
new one and reproduce it and when you
start reproducing this rule over and
over and over again you begin to get
structures that looked very much like
structures very complex fascinating
beautiful structures that look very much
like structures in the world
now
he's thinking computationally but not
computationally like the computations of
a computer
but computationally as in
choices over time
executing a rule consists of choices
over time in the same way that you
talked Wolfgang earlier about Mozart
getting a symphony all at once in his
head but then it over time he begins to
take that apart and lay out the
different parts for the various
instruments and then get all the music
written then the music is basically like
uh
a set of symbols that the musicians read
and they reconstitute the symphony so
their com computationally reconstituting
that Symphony
so when Stephen Wolfram is talking about
a computational universe that's the way
I picture it it's more like this rule is
executing
a symphonic structure
and um
the the thing that I I have been playing
around a little bit is what if the one
rule is love
what if love is the one rule that's
that's always recalibrating
when when we mess up and screw things up
and start going the wrong direction love
just institutes and other recalibration
and always making a path for us not
fixing things but maybe putting
obstacles in our path that will allow us
to learn what we need to learn in order
to move to the next step
I got fascinated with Jordan Peterson's
chapter on anomaly in maps of meaning
Jonathan that's where I started thinking
about obstacles and how important they
are in terms of growth whether at our
level or at the level of a cell or
anyplace else obstacles are like um
obstacles are the gift
well for sure in the but in the biblical
story you see
something like that which is you can see
a manner in which
let's say love covers all faults
something like that it may be the best
way to understand it where you you have
a sense in which the breaking the
breaking is a scandal so you have the
fall for example but then what happens
is God is constantly covering over and
transforming the fall into into more
let's say and so let's say a good
example that I've used before is that
you have the fall you have Cain kills
his brother because he kills his brother
then he found civilization civilization
brings War brings chaos brings the end
of a world basically
but then God uses the very tropes of
building and of civilizations to build
the ark and so the ark becomes a manner
in which all of this breaking down and
multiplicity gets re brought brought
back together into a microcosm which
then you know traverses the chaos and
you see then that repeated in the image
of the Tabernacle and then the temple
where the very tools of Cain right the
very tools of civilizations are kind of
recaptured and then brought in in a
manner that they manifest now a deeper
love and the final image of course is
the Heavenly Jerusalem which saves Cain
basically right it's like it's it really
is this beautiful Loop right from the
outside of the Fall where Cain found the
first city and then we end with this
image of the city which surrounds the
garden so you have the garden you have
Abel and Cane you have the garden and
the city and this is the totality of
what the process led to and so the the
multiplicity appears as kind of can
appear as Scandal but then there's a man
in which God is constantly filling that
scandal with love and and then and then
compensating for it
very very interesting
let me ask you this Jonathan uh
my understanding of uh
uh the art in the to in the Orthodox
tradition is that
iconography to be an iconographer is
almost like being a deacon I mean it
involves a certain uh spiritual
connection it's not what you do just as
an individual by yourself you do it as a
member of the church and uh
there's a spiritual side to it and there
are also certain rules that you need to
obey
is it still the way things are today and
which should be sadly of course we we do
live in the modern world where things
are chaotic and people that say
do whatever they want but I would say
that ideally in my case for example I
definitely ask for the blessing of my
Bishop uh and he he gave his Blessing by
giving me my first commission it's
actually my Bishop who gave me my first
commission and so there's a manner in
which
you know even if it's not done in in
official ways like it's not a Sacrament
right there's no there's no ritual to to
decide who an iconographer will be yeah
but there is a more organic manner in
which uh iconographers and their work
will be accepted into the church by
receiving commissions by by being asked
to decorate churches for example which
is usually the those are the The Shining
examples of iconography in the church uh
and then the rules there's a language
it's the best way to understand it
there's a there's an internal language
like any poetic language or any musical
language there's a there's an internal
language and it's flexible so you know
you can
you can make it consonant if you make it
two consonant then it's boring right and
if you if you make it too dissonant then
people don't recognize it and don't want
to integrate it into the community and
so you find that balance of play between
a kind of consonants with the that which
has been given to you but also a breath
let's say of of freshness which is
related to you being a person in
embodied person that's living out your
life and so you you'll see iconographers
that tend more towards a kind of
rigorism and then you'll see
iconographers which go wildly into
experimentation uh and you hope that
ultimately as the big ship of the church
goes down the goes down the river that
these things balance themselves out
let's say but the most extreme
iconographer is usually at some point
will will will be ignored by the church
or will will just be kind of set aside
very interesting I I think this is an
area in which the Orthodox church has
done better than the Catholic
because in the Catholic world as I see
it
um
iconography in the strict sense of the
term has been lost more or less at the
time of the Renaissance
when it was decided that Geniuses like
Michelangelo should be given free hands
to decorate our churches
trouble began because
I I strongly believe that if you look at
Michelangelo's
uh
paintings yeah the creation
it's a horrible image it's a horrible
image I mean it is it is more like Greek
mythology and Christianity I mean what
you're seeing is not Christ you're
seeing Apollo yeah and uh I think from
who are the naked teenagers next to God
in the creation like who are these naked
teenagers why why is this happening why
do we look at this image
so we've kind of connected back
and in a sense uh we have lost sacred
art our art is no longer sacred and this
is a bad thing because in religion
everything should be sacred even the
ground you walk upon so
this has been a problem
and uh in this regard
we have a lot to learn from the Orthodox
Churches which have preserved
these
Traditions which are very important
there there are some interesting places
tradition cultures that have remained in
their folk tradition seem to actually
have been better at preserving uh the
more iconographic aspect of Christian
art and so if you go to a church in
Mexico for example like a folk Church in
Mexico which you'll find in the church
although they have no contact with the
medieval tradition or with uh with
Orthodox iconography you'll find
something which is much closer to the
sensibilities and the the theological
care that you would find in the in
Orthodox icons uh so so it's an
interesting it has to do with a very
deep deep problem a deep shift in
Consciousness which I think appeared in
the west of course during during that
same time
well I I think that when they introduced
perspective
in sacred art they destroyed sacred art
because the whole point of sacred art is
that it deals with the spiritual world
instead of the material world
and uh
perspective
belongs to the material world it does
not belong to this spiritual world where
there is no distance at all so it seems
to me that
this is an important
aspect of our decline in in losing sake
it up we lost something that is
absolutely essential you can't really do
without it
and uh we're paying the price
and I would tie that back to Karen's
question about coherence over time right
that coherence over time comes from
the spiritual world
yes to try to find it in the material
world
yeah and also you can't find it right
and that's why Wolfgang's a platonist
in essence right
I hope so
well you can see that the worship of the
individual genius uh the worship of
innovation all of these things which
started to burgeon at the time of the
Renaissance you know has led to a
breakdown of of Catholic sacred art you
know the the churches it got just worse
and worse until Vatican II and and now
it's a dismal dismal State although I
would say that because of how dismal it
became in the 1970s like 60s 70s maybe
even before that starting in the 40s it
became so dismal that that right now
there's in some ways a a Reviving of the
traditional language because
there's nothing left to do all those
ugly churches no one everybody hates
them no one wants them and and so we can
see them as this these faded you know
you know very dated uh innovations that
no one cares about anymore and so the
only place to go at this point is a
rediscovery of the traditional language
hopefully not doing it in a way that is
too much of a of a Pastiche or just a a
Nostalgia for the past but rather
entering into the language like any
musical or or our poetic language and
learning the Rhymes learning the form so
that you can now create something which
is both new but also in tune with the
ancient patterns
unfortunately it's much easier to
destroy something than to build it up
well so Wolfgang this is one of the
reasons I wanted you to meet Jonathan
because I know that you've been
concerned about the future of the world
about the future of um of the faith and
I wanted you to meet Jonathan because
he's this entirely new generation and
he's bringing along with him a lot of
other young men and women who are um
catching the same vision and so I wanted
you to meet somebody who's in this
little corner of the internet
um
having an impact with these deep and
ancient truths I hope it's encouraging
to you it is very encouraging
in in fact
uh
I couldn't be more encouraged we we need
that
um
there has been a disorientation
which uh is very very difficult to
repair
and
I think we have a lot to learn from the
Orthodox tradition I thank God that it's
still functional it's alive and well
that is very encouraging
it's been wonderful to learn about your
work Jonathan
um I too am really encouraged I think
it's also just to kind of bring the two
together
you know I think what Wolfgang's work
does is kind of
from a very credible
uh scientist right
um shows the reductio out of certain
that science has uh created you know the
impasse that we're all at today and then
opens people to a reconsideration of
okay well if I can't understand the
world this way
how can I understand the world and then
that opens us back up to conversations
about the role of religion legitimate
role of religion and the differences
between different religions and I think
our conversation today and getting into
some of the nuances about Christianity
which I really hope people and we as a
culture will reconsider and revisit
because I think we need it and I think
that that Wolfgang your work in some
ways when you were publishing was so out
of tune with Academia was so
counter-cultural was just like just
smashing into into the system in ways
that was also difficult for people to
ignore because of because of your
credentials and your your your
credibility in terms of academic
capacity and its intellectual capacity
and I hope and I and I hope that we see
the fruits of all those years of effort
now that we can start to notice is that
even people who who are coming at it
through different means or coming at it
through different roads are coming to
the conclusions that you came at
you know decades ago uh and that in some
ways it's going to it's going to be seen
in in retrospect as a as really
pioneering for what is coming in the
future because there's no other way to
go beside the way that you set for us so
thank you for all your work well
I do believe that
we are heading for a to a point where
something new will have to come into
play
um and uh I'm of course hopeful actually
what I represent is nothing new I I'm
just to play a Christian platonist
doing his best not to mess up and
misconstrue things but to present them
as they are
and uh
down the road I think
our civilization
perhaps will be receptive to reconsider
these basic problems uh I do believe
that
things are breaking down
for example
physics is in a complete chaos
the the
non-specialist doesn't know much about
it but for example
particle physics is almost a joke I mean
it's it's it it's a reduction
which no sane person can take seriously
anymore and so something will have to
give sooner or later and I don't think I
will live to see it but I don't think
it's that far
far away from us
and uh I can't tell you Jonathan how
thrilled I am to hear what you had to
say and to see uh
real wisdom and real tradition flowering
and expressing itself in a contemporary
way that's wonderful
okay thank you
it's been a delight to spend the morning
with you all and uh next week I'm going
to have Wolfgang on again with John for
baky again if they've talked once and
they're going to be talking again
so um I'm very excited for that thank
you all for giving me so much time and
uh maybe we can do this again sometime
in the meantime have a have a wonderful
day
thanks everybody thank you bye-bye